terminamos el vídeo anterior con la
configuración electrónica para el neón
muy bien y que de hecho era 1s 212 c 226
y te mostré cómo podríamos fijarnos en
la tabla periódica y digamos que
podríamos deducir estas configuraciones
electrónicas por ejemplo sería para el
neón sería 1 s 1 1 s 2 muy bien y aquí
teníamos el 2 s 2 verdad con estos dos
elementos y después aquí teníamos 6 de
ellos que es lo que nos daba 2 p 6 muy
bien y así es como llegamos a la
configuración electrónica del neón
verdad ahora vámonos con la
configuración electrónica de los
elementos en el tercer periodo aquí
teníamos el primer periodo segundo
periodo y ahora vamos con el tercer
periodo así que hagamos primero el sodio
muy bien el sodio tiene 11 electrones de
hecho es uno más que el neón verdad pero
la segunda capa ya está llena en la
segunda capa está
llena así que para el onceavo electrón
del sodio necesitamos introducirnos en
la tercera capa verdad en el tercer
nivel de energía así que en ese caso n
será igual a 3 muy bien n será igual a 3
y l puede tener distintos valores l
puede ser 0 l puede ser uno o bien l
puede ser 2 en el primer caso tendremos
un orbital s en el segundo caso
tendremos orbitales p y serán tres de
ellos y en el tercer caso tendremos
orbitales de y tenemos cinco de ellos y
esto último lo podríamos ver simplemente
de observar el número y el número
magnético cuántico muy bien así que
vamos a graficar digamos estos orbitales
en términos de su energía verdad que va
a ir incrementando así que podríamos
poner digamos la flecha de la de la
energía que va aumentando en esta
dirección
aquí irá aumentando la energía en esta
dirección y ahora podríamos ir colocando
los los orbitales verdad así que estamos
en el tercer nivel de energía estamos en
el tercer nivel de energía y si nos
fijamos primero tenemos un orbital es de
verdad en esta tercera capa así que
tenemos tenemos sólo uno de ellos vamos
a pintarlo digamos por aquí aquí tenemos
nuestro orbital 3s déjenme ponerle un
poquito más arriba tenemos nuestro
orbital 3s muy bien y después tenemos
los orbitales de verdad que son tres
vamos a poner esos orbitales que se
encuentran digamos por aquí estos son
los orbitales 3 p muy bien y en esta
tercera capa también tenemos orbitales
de muy bien y tenemos cinco de ellos
tenemos 55 orbitales vamos a pintarlos
justamente por aquí
2 3 4 5 aquí tenemos nuestros orbitales
3d así que con esto regresemos al
problema del sodio verdad del sodio
tiene 11 electrones y los primeros 10
electrones los perdones primeros 10
electrones podríamos ponerlos justo como
el neón verdad así que vamos a poner el
sodio tiene sus primeros 10 electrones
justo igual que el neón muy bien ahí
está y recordemos que los super índices
nos dicen justamente el número de
electrones que llevamos así que serían
dos más dos son cuatro más seis son 10
pero tenemos 11 electrones así que
tenemos que acomodar este onceavo
electrón en la tercera capa muy bien y
digamos que el orbital de menor energía
sería el orbital 3s muy bien así que
colocamos este onceavo electrón en el
orbital 3s y con esto podríamos
completar la configuración electrónica
del sodio tendríamos 1
22.26 y tendríamos 3 s 1 simplemente
porque tenemos un electrón en un orbital
es de verdad en la tercera capa y eso
completa la configuración electrónica
para el sodio y ahora no tenemos no
tenemos que toda esta parte toda esta
parte es la misma configuración
electrónica que el neón así que
podríamos representarlo todo esto de
otra forma podríamos expresar al cne al
sodio perdón y todo esto simplemente lo
vamos a poner como un neón entre
corchetes con 3 s 1 y esto simplemente
es otra forma de escribir una
configuración electrónica para el sodio
que podríamos llamarlo digamos la
notación de gases nobles simplemente
porque estamos usando un gas noble que
precede al sodio por ejemplo aquí
podríamos ver fácilmente que el gas
noble que que precede al sodio en este
caso sería el neón verdad sería
es el gas noble que precede al sodio y
en resumen simplemente agregamos este
neón que es el gas noble que lo antecede
y agregamos después los electrones
correspondientes al sodio simplemente
porque la configuración del neón se
repite para el sodio y en realidad esta
anotación de gases nobles si nos sirve
mucho para ahorrarnos tiempo verdad
simplemente estamos diciendo que la
configuración electrónica del neón se
copia y después agregamos 3s 1 para el
caso del sodio así que vamos a seguir
ahora con digamos con el aluminio
sigamos ahora con el aluminio
y sigamos también con el color amarillo
muy bien vamos a utilizar la anotación
de gases nobles para ahorrarnos algo de
tiempo así que si por ejemplo nosotros
escribimos aluminio el primer el primer
gas noble que lo anteceden nuevamente es
el neón verdad sí nos vamos hacia atrás
en la tabla periódica el neón es el que
lo antecede muy bien entonces podríamos
poner neón entre corchetes
y ahora déjenme usar otro color muy bien
vamos a usar azul y ahora tenemos el
sodio verdad tenemos el sodio por aquí
que se nos da un electrón 3s 1 luego
seguimos con el magnesio que sería 3s 2
muy bien
de hecho ese electrón del magnesio
déjenme ponerlo en nuestra gráfica de
orbitales van a extraer nuestra nuestra
anotación de orbitales aquí lo tenemos
con una espina hacia abajo distinto al
que ya teníamos para el sodio y después
seguimos con el aluminio y como el
orbital 3s ya está completo entonces el
siguiente electrón que hay que acomodar
sería en uno de los orbitales 3 p muy
bien colocamos este electrón en uno de
los orbitales 3 p
y esto simplemente nos da como escribir
la configuración electrónica del
aluminio ya teníamos justamente los
mismos que el neón después agregamos 3s
2 verdad porque el 3s ya está completo
con 2 electrones y después tenemos un
electrón en un orbital 3 p entonces
tenemos 3 p 1 muy bien y esta es la
configuración electrónica para el
aluminio así que ahora vamos a saltarnos
a otro vamos ahora a saltarnos hasta el
argón muy bien vamos a hacer el argón y
nuevamente vamos a utilizar la notación
de gases nobles muy bien entonces el
primer gas noble antes que el argón
vuelve a ser el neón verdad y nuevamente
pensamos en cómo están acomodados los
elementos en la tabla periódica verdad
por ejemplo este sería 3s 1 3 s 2
después nos vamos con los orbitales 3 p
verdad sería 3 p 1 3 p 2 3 p 3
p 43 p 5 y finalmente el argón sería 3 p
6 muy bien y si queremos acomodar esos
electrones en esta en este diagrama pues
tendremos que utilizar la regla de junto
del cual hablamos en el vídeo anterior
verdad así que primero colocamos los
electrones de forma con el espín
paralelo en los orbitales 3p y después
irán con el espín invertido muy bien ahí
los tenemos y de hecho ya hemos llenado
todos los orbitales 3 p verdad así que
así tenemos el argón y podemos escribir
su configuración electrónica en este
caso sería 3 s 2 3 p
6 vamos a continuar ahora con el potasio
muy bien en el potasio nos encontramos
en el cuarto periodo de la tabla
periódica y en realidad para el potasio
podrías pensar que simplemente
subimos en uno de los orbitales tres de
verdad podrías pensar que eso sería el
siguiente paso sin embargo bueno eso eso
tiene sentido colocar el electrón en un
orbital d pero en realidad eso no es lo
que pasa verdad así que vamos a quitar
este electrón que habíamos puesto de
forma digamos intuitiva en este lugar y
lo que ocurre es lo siguiente como
estamos en el cuarto periodo en realidad
podríamos abrir una nueva capa aquí
verdad de hecho en este caso tendríamos
que n es igual a 4 verdad y tendríamos
varias posibilidades para el valor de l
fijémonos sólo en el valor de l igual a
cero eso nos dice que tenemos un orbital
es verdad
no vamos a escribir el resto de los
valores para él eso lo haremos en su
debido momento pero definitivamente
tenemos un orbital ese que está en el
cuarto nivel de energía sin embargo el
orbital 4s tiene es de menos de energía
ligeramente menor energía que los
orbitales 3-d así que déjenme pintarlo
con otro color
digamos con un azul un poco más oscuro
y quizás un poco más oscuro vamos a
ponerlo aquí y este sería el orbital 4 s
ok creo que no se ve muy bien vamos a
ponerlo con otro tipo de azul vamos a
ponerlo con este azul muy bien aquí se
encuentra el orbital 4s que es
ligeramente más bajo en energía que los
orbitales 3d así que el siguiente
electrón del potasio tendrá que ir en el
orbital 4 s muy bien así que si nos
fijamos en la configuración electrónica
del potasio que y vamos a escribir la
configuración electrónica del potasio y
utilizando la anotación de gases nobles
nos fijamos en él en el gas noble
inmediato anterior al potasio que en
este caso sería nuevamente bueno ya no
sería el neón ahora sería el argón así
que en esta anotación sería argón entre
corchetes y ahora
tenemos un electrón extra el electrón
número 19 que lo acabamos de colocar en
el orbital 4 es muy bien así que
simplemente colocamos 4 s
si ahora por ejemplo nos fijamos en el
calcio verdad que tiene 20 electrones el
gas noble que lo antecede sería
nuevamente el argón pero ahora tenemos
un electrón más que en el caso del
potasio así que ese electrón lo podemos
colocar en este orbital 4 veces y
quedaría completo verdad eso nos dice
que el que la configuración electrónica
del calcio es 4 ese 2 verdad argón 4 ese
2 y con esto podríamos observar
nuevamente un patrón en nuestra tabla
periódica verdad dejen de usar un color
azul en este caso verdad porque
podríamos ver que aquí está el 1 y el 1
s 1
2 s 12 s 23 s 13 s 24 s 14 s 2 verdad
entonces podríamos pensar que todo esto
es como el bloque de orbitales s ahora
bien los siguientes elementos con los
que nos vamos a topar son todos estos
todos estos digamos de esta de esta fila
en el cual ahora sí tenemos que recordar
que en el tercer nivel teníamos 5
orbitales 3 de verdad en este caso
teníamos 5 orbitales de para el nivel 3
muy bien además cada uno de estos
orbitales pueden mantener un máximo de 2
electrones así que si tenemos 5
orbitales y 2 electrones
eso nos da 10 verdad fijémonos en
cuántos espacios tenemos tenemos 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 así que estos 10 espacios
corresponden a los que tienen electrones
en el oro en los orbitales 3 de pero eso
los vamos a trabajar en un vídeo
separado ok vamos a trabajar en un vídeo
distinto los orbitales de no nos vamos a
preocupar por ellos con mucho detalle en
estos momentos pero tenemos 10 espacios
verdad que es parte de la tercera capa y
tenemos 10 espacios para esos electrones
así que
digamos que en la configuración
electrónica 3 de 10 llenarían todos
estos espacios muy bien y por eso están
colocados de esa manera en la tabla
periódica ahora vámonos con el siguiente
elemento que en nuestro caso sería el
galio muy bien así que si estamos usando
la notación de gases nobles el gas noble
que lo antecede sería el argón muy bien
y si nos fijamos en esta zona tendríamos
4 s 14 s 2 así que escribimos 4 s 2 y
luego tenemos todos los de los que se
encuentran en esta fila verdad que sería
3 de 10 porque ya estarían completos y
ahora nos queda un electrón más y eso
nos podemos acomodar simplemente porque
nos encontramos en la cuarta en el
cuarto nivel de energía aunque l podría
ser 0 también l podría ser 1 y eso nos
dice que tendríamos orbitales p y
tendríamos tres de ellos muy bien y es
aquí en donde empezamos a colocar los
electrones en los orbitales de verdad
empezamos a llenar los orbitales p con
electrones del cuarto nivel de energía y
así tendríamos un electrón para el galio
que se encuentra en un orbital 4 p así
que simplemente completamos con 4 p
1 muy bien ahora bien aquí hay algo que
mencionar y es que en ocasiones puede
ser que observes que estos dos están
invertidos es decir que la configuración
electrónica del galio para el argón sea
3 de 10 4 s 24 pero no simplemente
invirtiendo esto si en realidad no
importa cómo lo escribas lo podrás ver
de ambas formas muy bien ahora vamos a
seguir con otro elemento vámonos directo
hasta el crypton vámonos directo hasta
el crypton y será nuestra última
configuración electrónica de este vídeo
si nos fijamos en el el gas noble que lo
antecede y si nos fijamos en el gas
noble que lo antecede sería el argón muy
bien
y vamos a utilizar otro color para ir
viendo cómo rellenar la configuración
electrónica del crypton verdad después
del argón tenemos estos dos que nos da
en su configuración electrónica 4 s 2
después tenemos todos los que rellenan
los orbitales de verdad todos estos
todos estos eso nos da 3 de 10 y después
tenemos todos estos verdad que nos
rellenan los orbitales p del cuarto
nivel así que tendríamos 4 p 6 y esa
sería una forma de representar la
configuración electrónica para el
crypton y nuevamente estos dos podrían
haber sido intercambiados podríamos
haber escrito 3 de 10 4 s 2 4 p 6 pero
en realidad no importa cómo lo
escribamos quizás deberías más bien
seguir las indicaciones de tu profesor
para este tipo de situaciones y con esto
hemos cubierto el tercer y cuarto
periodos pero hemos ignorado los
orbitales de nuevamente lo veremos en un
vídeo por separado porque puede volverse
un poquito complicado cuando traba
jamás con orbitales de